This isn't an algorithm because the procedure doesn't always terminate. Let's
try running it on the example I gave. Initially, it's not an order. So, Robby
would locate the first two bricks that don't match and swap them. Now, they're
still not in order. So again, Robbie would find the first pair of blocks that
doesn't match. And swap them. We're now back exactly where we started. If
Robbie keeps doing the same thing, again and again, he'll always end up right
back where he started. The bricks will never end up in order. So this is not an
algorithm. Robbie's batteries will run out before this algorithm finishes, or
all the batteries and generators in the world would run out before this process
finishes. He will never finish.